before all of this you know you
mentioned your Hollywood years and the
first book came out in 96 and you said
very publicly that you went back to the
literary world to write bigger than you
were allowed to write or in film and
television
so how surprised were you that you were
even approached for an adaptation of
something you had written specifically
not for film and television well you
know I began to be approached
around the time Clash of Kings came out
and even more when stormer source came
out those were the first two books to
actually hit the bestseller lists Game
of Thrones did okay but we didn't hit
any list but the serious bills so Clash
of Kings you know hit the New York Times
listed like number thirteen for one week
and storm swords was a little higher in
the list and lasted a few more weeks and
at that point I started getting these
enquiries from from Hollywood and I
thought at the time well these these
guys don't know what they're talking
about here they don't know that it's
impossible to do yeah and some of them
indeed didn't they were just looking at
the list you know the Lord of the Rings
movies we're making an obscene amount of
money and were gigantic hits so
Hollywood is basically imitative so at
the time that the Lord of the Rings
movies were setting these box-office
records a lot of the studios and
producers were looking around saying
well what other fantasies are out data
we can buy and they all started buying
fantasies and you know we've seen a few
of them I'm in Narnia subsequently made
it to the screen Philip Pullman's His
Dark Materials the first book made it to
the screen and they came looking for
mine but I took a few meetings I'm
always willing to take a meeting I got
some free lunches out of it
and they would present their ideas to me
of how they would adapt these into into
movies what to adapt them into movies to
get you know and they weren't even
talking about one book they were talking
about the entire series they wanted to
know how it ended so they could figure
out how to wrap it up and they would say
things like well it's it's really the
story of Daenerys so we'll we'll
eliminate these other characters we'll
just focus on Daenerys or on Jon Snow or
on Ned in some cases and
and like do you know what happens yes
well we'll have to change that part so I
listened and I ate two free lunches but
I didn't I didn't by for any of those
but it did get me thinking that the only
way to do this was was not for the
feature film as much as I would have
liked to have a two hundred million
dollar budget I thought it was better to
tell the entire story with all of the
characters and all the complexity and
the only way to do that is television
and not any television either because
you can't that is too much graphic sex
and graphic violence and too much
complexity for network television the
network's would would be too leery of it
they would water it down too much so it
had to be premium cable and and HBO of
course is the Tiffany's of that doing
doing more shows and better shows and of
course I've been a huge HBO fan for ages
I've had HBO for god I don't even want
to think how long but shows like
Deadwood and Rome in particular showed
me that they would have people who could
really really do this and I met David
Benioff and Dan Weiss and they had the
same idea and would that was a match
made in heaven